okay so this is what I'm looking at
you'll recognize this is what we
finished doing this royal fish drink
earlier the approximate area American
thing so we are looking at the cost of
electrical energy because this is
mathematics and resources and
electricity is a pretty important
resource let's have a look for th
question 1 use the sample electricity
account for the following page to answer
these questions now as we go through
this I'm just going to point out there
are lots of phrases where you let boys
not even be ok
I've already you know II mark some of
them in my head so that I can tell you
this is one that's a bit unusual maybe
don't know what that is but if I go
through them then I don't stop and you
want to know then precisely this is why
we're doing this we're not doing this so
you can answer questions we're doing the
simple understand how to read your bills
on other things what is the supply
period form is bill supply period what
do you think that means the time in
which they supply electricity to you now
have a look this is a big bill there's a
lot of information here ok so I'm going
to give you a bit of a tip if you scroll
sort of down to the bottom the supply
period you should be able to find there
it's close to the bottom where is it you
see it I will look I'll go in a bit
further for you you see them so it says
power smart home electricity usage
summary they're not written to be easy
to read but once you get used to it you
can hear it just apply creative out
there so if you've got your book there
the first one one a money
the answer is supply period is the 22nd
of November in that year so the 22nd of
February that's the supply tree that's
what starts when it ends the next
question says how many days is this now
you can't calculate it but you don't
need to because it says right there 93
days so tell me how many times a year do
you get never see them four times a year
these are quarterly 93 days about three
months okay but it has a awkward time
20 second it that depends a lot on when
you first sign up for electricity
not everyone signs up on the first day
of the month so this is the 22nd okay
one be the electricity service
availability charge is a charge for
having electricity available to your
properties think about that even without
using electricity they charge you
because stuff like equipment and all of
the wires and poles they cost money or
depending on where you live under
Interpol's everything is underground
okay so they charge you for that so
we're looking for the daily charge for
service availability again step back
have a look
electricity service available do you see
it so it's underneath this heading here
energy used and costs it's right down
here at the bottom electricity service
availability charge and you can see if
you read from left to right for each
line item they give you important
information for example how much was
their service saleability
93 days what was the rate do you see
that what's the right there right there
that is the daily charge or service
availability so if there are outages
then you don't get charged as those
hello people anyone else
thank you okay how 30
the next thing says afterwards the daily
tried to calculate the total charge for
this account now you could go ahead and
you can calculate how would you
calculate it if that's the charge per
day you could multiply that by the
number of days you could do that except
don't because they're they've already
done that for you over there on the
right hand side okay so that's the total
charge just for service availability not
for actually using any electricity so
are you getting a sense of powdery this
it's not really complicated but because
I'm familiar that's why I've got to get
you a little
we'll do it people are just ahead for
the usage charges what you pay for the
amount of electricity that you use
what will the total electricity used by
this household for the billing period
okay now this is a bit interesting um I
won't go into here for the details but
do you see the units for the amount of
electricity the total amount of
electricity that's been used to see if
they're involved total electricity used
where is it which number is it's this
one right to see what that one there now
it says the reason I do this is what it
is is because of the left hand side it
says total electricity and then over
here this is the number now what are
those units when you see a que in front
of you what does that usually mean kilos
correct so you be likes actually where
you're writing your answers instead of
writing kWh you might like to write kilo
the W stands for what yeah what does it
stand for sense of what it is a beep
kilowatts kilowatt they are not a
measure of electricity that's been used
over a period of time okay kilowatts are
a rate a bit like a speed okay
so if I said to you hey uh how far how
far have you traveled over a certain
period of time and if you look at your
speedometer and it says 60 kilometers
per hour if the question is how far if
you traveled you can't say 60 kilometers
per hour because that's a rate does that
make sense you want there like a total
about the total amount would be for the
you know the distance might be say 60
kilometers okay you get that because you
say I'm just going to refer you this you
can say for example 60 kilometers per
hour and then you multiply that by how
long would either travel what else
sure that's right
so you can see in this case the hours
here and the allottee cancel so that's
why you'd say of course the total
distance is 16 kilometers that makes
sense
but 4 kilowatts there's no per hour in
the unit the actual thing itself that's
a rate so when you multiply it say by
one hour then that's one kilo watt oh
that's that's what to you know actually
means so I'm actually going to do this
kWh is short for kilo watt hours you
might have a heater and it's rated at
such-and-such a number of Watts right
let's just say it's a 5 watt here which
is very very small okay if you use that
for a thousand hours think about this
ring I did to displace 5 watts and you
use it for 1000 hours over the course of
the three months okay well just look at
the unit's five times a thousand five
thousand what are the units that I got
here what hours so these are five
thousand watt hours so if I convert that
to a more appropriate unit that's five
kilo watt hours does that make sense
it's a weed unit but it comes from the
time of kilowatts are rate just like
60,000 per hour is a great so let's come
back the question just said um what's
the total amount of electricity used so
the answer is what does an area hundred
sixty one point four kilowatt hours
what's the average daily usage average
daily usage now think about this you
could just simply divide we suggested
that before right you can say I you know
you could take the service charge
seventy four point seven cents you can
multiply it by 93 and that would give
you this number down here sixty nine
point four seven okay in the same way if
we had no other information I could take
that total amount of power and what
would I do with it
being that it was a 93 day two
/ 93 so that would give you the answer
however you're getting a trend here
electricity reports utility reports are
not designed for someone to use with a
calculator next to them they're mostly
dumping calculations for you till you
spot them right up there at the top you
see there in the quarter average daily
usage do you see that hey this woman are
please go ahead so you can see it's kind
of handy they compared last bill this
pill same period last year okay so
there's your number right there okay and
sure enough if you divide 1861 point
whatever by 93 I think you get 20 point
some small number okay